CBS News is shining a light on the
homeless crisis we do not see
working-class families left behind in
this economy our new eye on America
series Left Behind begins with the
plight of homeless children more than
1.3 million kids are homeless nationwide
CBS News contributor
Maria Elena Salinas met a California
family who are among the hidden homeless
and she joins us at the table to discuss
I'm so glad you're doing this story I'm
putting a face on the problem definitely
and the problem is a lot more serious
than we know
you know when Robert and Kristen Eddings
lost steady jobs they ended up homeless
they now live in a Los Angeles motel
room with their young children where
they've stayed for the past year I wish
I had probably I was six year old kai
and seven year old heaven are honor
students with big dreams for the future
I want to be a scientist because I won't
be smart
we met Kai and heaven in Los Angeles
career they have been homeless for two
years and living in this motel for the
past year do you understand why you live
in the motel oh I do but it's just you
don't have enough money that's it why
would you tell that
mommy said not oh you heard when we were
talking to the kids today we asked them
if they understood why they were living
in in this one town and heaven said
because we don't have any money I think
I turned around I said you're not
supposed to say that mom said not to say
that and they both covered their mouth
I'm sorry sue you tell them that yeah
yeah because we you don't I mean we
don't want them to feel out of place at
school we don't want to be the the pity
charity case you know at school or
anything like that I just want them to
be as normal as can be Robert and
Kristen Eddie's both lost steady jobs
Kristin was making fifty two thousand
dollars a year as a store manager while
Robert had a full-time job at a
janitorial company you know there's a
lot of misconceptions about homelessness
and about people who experience
homelessness what do you want people to
know about your situation that could
happen to anyone
yeah I never thought like I came up with
it you know middle-class family never
struggled with money that I knew of the
average rent in Los Angeles is more than
$2,500 a month a 65% increase in the
last ten years people here need to earn
close to seventy two thousand dollars a
year to afford a two-bedroom apartment
motels next to each other motels by the
hour unfortunately we have experienced
child abduction we have experienced
domestic violence many Flores is the
executive director of North Valley
caring services he helps hundreds of
families growing up in a motel is
traumatic in itself growing up in a
motel in some of these corridors where
there are so many criminal elements is
abusive I would say at the motel where
we met the eddies family there were more
than 30 assaults in over 20 incidents of
domestic violence reported last year
kaien heaven are two of the estimated
17,000 children who are homeless in the
LA Unified School District a staggering
85% of children in that district live in
poverty the official count of 17,000
probably closer to 30,000 Buettner is
the LA Unified School District
Superintendent what is the LA Unified
School District doing to help these
families so we're beginning to advocate
more to bring resource to schools we
actually receive zero incremental
dollars from the state to try to help
those families and students who may be
experiencing homelessness the district
has allocated five hundred section 8
housing vouchers for families but 76% of
them go one used because landlords
refused to rent to tenants with this
federal subsidy what do you want for
your family a house you said now the
Eddings family still lives in the motel
but robert was recently hired at a
magazine agency working in customer
service at least if some income is not
enough to rent us it's amazing that
those kids are on a roll yes that's
really impressive yeah that's because
the parents really focus on their kids
and making sure that they have some kind
of stability it's a reminder that the
cure for cancer could live in the mind
of a child sleeping in a hotel room
tonight
no and mom's still looking for a job but
they're still in the hotel because they
can't yet afford to be in a house yeah
not only can they not afford it but even
if they could afford it they don't have
a rental history so it's very difficult
for landlords to rent to someone that
doesn't have rental history all right
tough situation we're Elena thank you so
much